Let's talk today about the concept of the
lesser of two evils.
Are you evil if you choose the lesser of two
evils, or should you abstain altogether from
being involved in such a choice?
Now, of course, the context of all of this
is that there are people saying they're not
going to vote for Joe Biden instead of Donald
Trump, because Joe Biden is merely the lesser
of two evils.
There are people who see both Biden and Trump
as evils, although maybe to different degrees,
and voting for any evil would not be OK for
them.
So they might abstain or they might vote third
party or write someone in or whatever the
case may be.
Another way that some are saying it is those
who are focusing in on the sexual assault
component of the current political race.
There are people who write to me and say,
David, are you just saying I should choose
which sexual assault or I want either vote
for a sexual assault or with one allegation
against them or a sexual assault or with 26?
That's not a good choice for me.
I'm going to opt out.
So let's really think this through and take
it in pieces.
There's this first question of just arguing
like, is Biden evil or is Biden not that good?
Or like what what what exactly is the characterization
of Biden in this context?
I'm going to argue that it doesn't matter
to me.
It's a distraction to say, is Biden good or
simply less evil than Donald Trump?
Once you grant that Biden is better than Trump,
if you don't then vote for Trump, then there's
not even a conversation.
If you think Trump's better vote, vote for
Trump, that's clear.
But once you grant Biden is better than Trump,
I don't think it matters whether Biden is
less evil or good for the purposes of the
conversation we're going to have today.
Secondly, and this is really important.
The concept of opting out because you can't
vote for evil.
There is no opting out here, folks.
If you're an American and you are allowed
to vote, there is no opting out.
You can choose not to cast a ballot.
But from a left of Trump perspective, either
way you're participating, you're influencing.
You have a say, a stake, and you are you are
affecting the outcome, whether you cast the
ballot or not.
There are people making themselves sort of
feel okay about not voting for Biden by simply
saying I'm opting out.
I don't like the choices, so I'm not going
to participate in a literal sense.
You aren't taking the act of voting and going
and doing it, but you're not opting out of
the process.
If you vote for Trump, that's obviously a
vote against Biden.
If you don't vote at all and believe Biden
is less bad than Trump, but not good enough
for you to vote for him, you're still helping
Trump with one vote.
It's a vote that Trump does not need to overcome
in order to be reelected.
So let's really cut through the B.S. here.
Biden being evil or not isn't relevant.
If we agree he's better than Trump for our
purposes today, that's all that matters.
Opting out and being a non-actor in the process
is a rejection of both candidates.
Unless you renounce your citizenship and aren't
allowed to vote, you have a vote.
Whether you use it or not, you are participating
and your actions are part of the ultimate
consequence.
So given all of that, this is actually quite
simple.
If you were put in a room with two buttons,
one button kills 10 people and one button
kills a million people.
And if you say I'm not going to press a button,
someone else can press the button for me.
Is there any question that you are acting
in a way that is improper?
Is there any question that you should obviously
press the button, given that one of these
two buttons is going to be pressed?
That saves nine hundred and ninety nine thousand
nine hundred and ninety people.
Right.
Nine nine nine nine nine zero people.
Of course, you should press that button.
That would be choosing between the lesser
of two evils.
Killing 10 people is bad.
Killing one million people is also bad.
And I would argue it is worse, but it actually,
again, doesn't matter whether you're choosing
between two evils.
Because think about a slightly different scenario
than the one I just gave you.
You're in the same room.
There are also two buttons.
One button kills a million people and the
other kills no one and resurrects one person.
It brings back someone that died of a car
accident.
OK.
Imagine that isn't the right action.
Obvious in both cases.
Resurrect one person versus kill 10 million.
Kill 10 versus kill 10 million.
Whatever the numbers are.
Right.
In either case, these are the choices.
And if you say leave it up to chance, leave
it up to other people or I can take the action
that I know is the preferable action.
Of course I take the preferable action anytime
now.
How do you justify taking any action that
could let other people press the kill a million
button?
In either case, I don't know how you justify
that.
This is why the debate about is Biden sort
of good but not that good versus is Biden
less bad than Trump?
It's irrelevant.
There is no responsible way to say I'm going
to let other people choose and I won't put
in my vote for the less bad or better option.
But if that was the full analysis, I would
be doing a disservice to this discussion.
There are philosophical structures that would
defend not pressing any button.
So I've sort of given you a more utilitarian
perspective.
But let's consider for a second.
The philosophy of Immanuel Kant, Kantian ism,
German philosopher from mostly the 18th century,
died in the first few years of the 19th century,
I believe.
You could certainly take a look at Kantian
ism, which is focused not on end goals like
I'm looking at the end goal when I say if
10 or a million are going to die, let me do
what I can to make it 10 instead of a million
Kantian ism instead of focusing on the end
goal would deal more with one's duty and acting
in accordance with underlying principles.
So if we focus on this lesser of two evils
idea and we look at it in terms of the principle,
one could have a Kantian aligned principle
of I'm not going to vote for bad people, that
I'm only going to exercise my vote when I
have someone good to vote for because of a
principle, I'm not going to do the utilitarian
focus on the end goal of killing fewer people.
I'm going to justify not pressing either button
because it would violate a principle of mine
rather than focusing on the harm reduction
utilitarian component.
But that's a fair argument that that would
be right out of Kantian ism.
I believe that even in this case, even in
this strict Kantian defense of the nonvotes
to adhere to a principle, I think it still
falls apart because in the case of voting
or not voting in the United States, both actions
are a form of participation.
Once again, whether you vote or not, you're
participating either way.
And what I mean by that is that the act of
voting in and of itself, like the cat, filling
out your ballot, mailing it in whatever it
is, in a moral sense, neutral.
Right.
Just filling out a piece of paper.
You're either filling out the piece of paper
or you're not filling out the piece of paper.
But once you understand that, either way,
you're participating in deciding the outcome.
You're no less of a participant by not voting.
You are no more adhering to the principle
that you were trying to adhere to in this
county in sense by not voting, whether you
vote for Trump or merely don't get in the
way of Trump by not voting, you are still
participating because voting is a right that
you have as an American.
You are either way participating in the outcome
and thus the non vote might make people feel
like they're opting out over principles and
having no impact, choosing not to participate.
But in reality, you are just as much of a
participant, whether you vote or not.
And thus even a Kantian ethic of adhering
to principles rather than focusing on utilitarian
end goals fails to justify a non vote.
In this case, let me know where I'm going
wrong.
I look forward to the discussion.